good all right weapon systems online
battle systems operational
is that from starcraft it is indeed
wow all crews reporting
and just in case there's any zoomers out
there we're talking about starcraft one
yeah
oh yeah no graphics for me they just
re-released that with like hd graphics
but they still maintained the original
styles they didn't make it 3d they just
like made the resolution of the sprites
nicer
dude i am the biggest sucker i always
buy the remakes of games i've already
finished you know baldur's gate
age of empires i keep buying the remakes
and i've probably bought them each like
four times at this point was one of the
worst
one i didn't get the starcraft one i
think i got my fill of that one
power defense i got a final fantasy
remastered it's the seventh one
what was that good they completely
changed it though it's not remastered so
much it's a different game
a new game with the same plot and
characters yeah and aren't they just
like releasing it episodically so you
can buy like the first 10 hours in the
next 10 hours or something oh yeah they
know how it's done these days
they know how to squeeze every last dime
out of my ass
yes they're gonna charge you like 80
bucks per per chapter and it'll end up
being like uh i don't know
five five chapters or something instead
of expansions it's part two
yeah exactly well this is exactly the
opposite if i hope the opening would go
because
victor has rightly pointed out we should
have
something of a standardized intro
because
i assume there's at least a couple new
people each time
well yeah i always think that if some if
like new
people come across our podcast and they
just like hear
the beginning and then they hear us like
ranting about starcraft and zoomers
they're just going to be like what is
this [ __ ]
so i feel like we should like to say
something
to structure we need some sort of
standardized institution to ground
the chaos here we we can't just have
like like nothing
uh yeah like some brand recognition like
we should all take like a
10 minute marketing course or something
like that and
try to make our brand something
recognizable
you know something like five seconds you
know like pops on
and you know so no one told me life was
gonna be this way
based on all the references so far uh
we're millennials
we're also mostly doctors
are trying to doctors yeah but not not
not the medical kind the real kind no
exactly the original kind
i like i love that joke like i need cpr
oh i've got the critique of pure reason
right here
that's the kind of doctor i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you guys ready to go on this
this is actually part two
of an episode that's true part two
of pillpod episode three but this is
currently
uh episode 48. was it really pill pod
three that this came up originally
yeah so we i mean we always say that
we're stuck on a loop
21 2021 is the same as 2020 and uh
guess who's back in the news giorgio
agamben
the best italian theorist ever
except for how many italian theories do
any of us really know
negri ah a couple
grams echo okay echo yeah antonio negri
isn't he
dottie speak of someone who's still
alive or was last time i saw her
live christine de pisan dante
losarto yeah is pizon italian victor
brezzoni
our favorite game name the italians all
of them
yeah so uh yeah we this episode we're
we're gonna call it conspiracy theory
versus critical theory
uh because they are kindred spirits and
we have already for a very long time
or a very long time ago discussed the
relationship of critical theory and
conspiracy theory uh they look the same
and we have some theorists that say
they're the same and at least when i say
conspiracy theory i don't really mean it
as something
that's necessarily false and
crazy it's a theory good or bad that
there is some conspiracy at play now it
might be good or bad theory
but saying something's a conspiracy
theory doesn't necessarily imply that
it's
crank well what's a conspiracy
breathing together
that's a good question though so
etymological i love it
it's i mean it's isn't it usually um
you know a small group of uh bad faith
actors
working in unison to bring about some
state of things or some favorable
outcome that will benefit themselves and
nobody
else that seems like a pretty good
definition and that's a secret
theory is that that's just going on in
the background any negative event that's
occurring oh there's like some cabal of
elites trying to bring this about
and we don't want it like anti-vaxx
is probably runs on that [ __ ] right oh
we can't do this
because it's bill and melinda gates and
the rest of the lizards want us to get
these microchips pumped into our arms
it's very silly stuff obviously
but i mean we gotta face it because it's
so
[ __ ] prevalent apparently i i'm
personally in the opinion that anybody
buys into the
lizard people conspiracy is actually in
on an even deeper conspiracy
so that's a key sign for you if they
start talking about lizards they're
trying to distract you from what's
really good conspiracy theory about
conspiracy theory we got
meta conspiracy theories here going matt
nice haircut by the way sorry
sorry listeners i just noticed that matt
has a haircut
literally you didn't notice this on
saturday and looks you you had this
haircut on saturday
yeah i'm just you know what it is i'm
used to seeing you like when you come on
straight out of the shower and and as as
one of our like you know left-wing
haters described you as
uh the that centrist sheepdog
and you don't you don't need you don't
uh you don't have that look anymore so
you couldn't be accused of being
that anymore gradually as coveted
restrictions have receded so too has my
hair so he never lets me he never lets
me in the shower so i just have to watch
from afar
don't worry one day so are we doing the
standard introduction are we just gonna
talk about doing it we're not doing it
no we're gonna
we're gonna talk about it and then maybe
do it in the future so that
people know that our interest is not in
sounding standardized
nor professional
one direction with like the sound we go
for for millennial podcast
i want to go the exact opposite
direction and suggest that we need like
nine inch nail pulses
like then like some nihilistic drumming
that comes in
distortion weird guitar and then we dive
right into it yeah so that's why
stuff try to hug your family that sounds
cool produce start learn how to produce
music now
pills in addition to all the other stuff
that you're doing yeah yeah
we're texts scholars you're everything
else anyway in terms of signification
friends uh conspiracy theories
give the world sort of a sense of
coherence
um in that they unite what you see and
what you can't see
what's visible or what's invisible
uh it comprises the visible in some way
even though it's malicious coherence
there might be some comfort in knowing
that at least someone's in control even
if they're evil people at least there's
some control out there yeah and i think
well
what's interesting just looking up the
sort of like the word conspiracy it's
like
a secret plan and i guess the idea
like where that would come in in some of
this kind of theorizing is i guess
there's a big emphasis by uh
to notice all these like forces going on
in the background that like none of us
um are aware of and to some extent like
that could be construed as secret
because
i guess the whole point of like bringing
them to light through the lens of theory
is to show
that they have a different signification
in the way that they're impacting us
that's like secret and
is influencing our behavior so in that
sense you could see it as conspiratorial
yeah i also think there is actually
genuinely something comforting and
thinking that
the people in control are genuinely in
control and not as competent
as incompetent as they sometimes appear
like if we had to face a cold hard
reality
the fact that doug ford really just is
an idiot uh and that donald trump just
really was an idiot who had no idea what
he was doing
that to me would be a lot more
terrifying than the notion that they're
actually secret geniuses playing 12 or
15 level chess
with for those for those who don't know
doug ford is the premier of ontario
the province in canada like the governor
also all madness and no method but it is
yeah it is
comforting to think there may be a
method but we do this not just with
conspiracy theory but
the the relation i was trying to draw
with critical theory there is
we have terms like hegemony or
capitalist ideology that sort of fill
exactly that whole like if we didn't
have this secret
managerial operation if we didn't have
the media spectacle
deceiving everybody then everyone would
get to
get along great and we could forge our
ideal utopia without the nefarious
influence
of forces that we can't see well i think
there's a big difference though
which is that there are definitely
conspiracy theories out there right i
think i'm just saying that the structure
is almost the same so what is the
structure so what are we talking about
right now i think the difference is
exactly that that you know leftists tend
to look for
structural reasons that exceed human
agency or even understanding for
why it is that systems of power
replicate themselves whereas
with a lot of the right-wing conspiracy
theorists that you see coming out of the
woods right now the idea
is that power structures are
deliberately created
and maintained by some shadowy cabal
that keeps on shifting depending upon
the time
so there's this deliberate a gentle
quality that you don't find
in most left-wing kinds of critical
theory
well maybe you can answer me this don't
you think though that
the way that a lot of uh
i mean i hate using the term but online
marxist people so they kind of blame
capitalism and then imply that if we
didn't have capitalism
then everyone would be a better person
no 100 i mean that's what i'm saying
there are left-wing conspiracy theories
out there like i think
let's just use marx as an example a proc
for marxist analysis
of the dynamics of capitalism hegemony
would say that there can be very nice
capitalists
who don't even know what they're really
doing uh they're just competing with
other capitalists in the market and they
reproduce
systems of exploitation and hegemony as
a result of their actions
it's not deliberate right uh this can
very quickly be given a
more conspiratorial caste though if you
start saying things like oh people are
actually
all banding together in order to create
more exploitative conditions
uh and what we need to do is kind of
peel back the layers of the undine
to figure out which group of capitalists
are the ones that are ultimately
actually in charge and create this kind
of system right
and every now and then like we've all
given into like our
capitalist bashing every now and then
like i was making fun of bezos a few
days ago
right uh you know the kind of proper
marxist analysis to say it's about
structures not people
uh whereas the more conspiratorial bent
that i can give into is starting to say
that this is a deliberate
system of oppression created by a group
of people who know what they're doing
and don't care
yeah but then then when you get into
conspiracy
conspiratorial thinking right that's
where the parallels between
you know critical theory and conspiracy
theories start to emerge
because it's a kind of this is this the
way that
litur describes it we we did an episode
way back on
on bruno latour and he made this exact
sort of comparison
well he says well while conspiracists
like
to portray a miserable bunch of greedy
people with dark intents
i litura finds something troublingly
similar
in the structure of the explanation in
the first movement of this belief
and then in the wheeling of causal
explanations coming out of
the deep dark below there's a sort of
causal explanation causal explanatory
similarity
in that you don't believe the things
you're presented with
you you become suspicious of of where
they're from or what they're
designed to achieve and then you start
to draw on this sort of
just this free-floating theoretical
apparatus whether it's
what you get from from whatever it is
now 8chan 4chan
or or what you get from pierre bourdieu
as as gives the example of
it's structurally there's a kind of
similarity between
critical theory and conspiracy theory
but we like to say
you know like marxism right like that's
that's on a scientific basis
it's demonstrable and it's not pointing
out some cabal of people because we know
that even under capitalism the big
powers have very different and divergent
interests
but you know it's easy to forget that
especially dealing with
individual areas of sectors of the
economy right like
whatever amazon or whatever tesla has
domination over it's
it then does seem like there is a kind
of
conspiracy at work i don't know what you
say i mean conspiracies are real but
doesn't that kind of thinking in theory
kind of start with what the
who was it that identified the
hermeneutics of suspicion right it's
like that kind of transition
in theory and philosophy with
the advent of like freud marx and
nietzsche and the whole idea was that
like the three of them kind of signified
a shift in philosophy where they where
they started to say that like oh you
think you
you think like morality is something
benign in the case of nietzsche but
actually it's like this nonsense that
you don't understand hidden there's like
hidden understanding
same with like marks with like
capitalism and same with like you know
your own conscious like desires in freud
that all these things like underneath
um what you think is like the common
sense understanding of how you
experience those things there's actually
like hidden forces
that are actually influencing those
things which i think influences and
starts to
structurally create the conditions for
what seems to kind of map on to this
conspiratorial thinking in theory
i have not done this yet but if my next
video does
poorly i'm going to join every other
leftist youtuber
in blaming capital interest for
conditioning the algorithm to avoid
leftist videos
there's a conspiracy though i think that
this gesture does have deeper roots even
though than the or even then the
origins of modern critical theory right
with somebody like counter marks or
wherever you want to pinpoint it right
because one of the things that's
emblematic about classical philosophy
and that's still emitting about many
streams of conservative philosophy
as also is a search for deep structures
or transcendent structures
uh but the implication usually is that
they're good or benevolent right
and that they'll affirm the legitimacy
of the present and the past
right uh whereas what was really
innovative about left-wing critical
theory was to invert this expectation
and say that
once you understand deep structures uh
not only they are not transcendent but
they're material
and they're also often very often very
malicious right
they impose discipline on people or they
exploit people or they convince people
to accept their own
exploitation et cetera and i do get what
eric is saying
which is sometimes this search for deep
structure whether on the part of
conservative who wants a transcended
affirmation of the present
uh or a critical theorist who wants to
deconstruct the present to reveal its
contingency
can sometimes be problematic and
represent a kind of pathological drive
for meaning
uh that where there just isn't any
meaning to be found right and i think
that
one of the reasons sometimes why things
like woke culture can be frustrating
uh is people can always be searching for
the presence of these kinds of deep
structures
in the actions of individual people so
they can diagnose them as
bad or signifying some kind of deep
system of oppression
when sometimes people just want to be
treated like they are at the surface
right they want what they say to be
accepted at that level
without people trying to mythologize it
and more deeply than that
well matt you sound like you're pretty
confident in being able to tell the
difference between
critical theory and conspiracy theory so
i have prepared a game for you
to test your skills the three of you
it's called ct
or ct
[Laughter]
which means that i spent the day on a
reddit r slash conspiracy
found a bunch of comments and then put
them next to some of
the quotes of our favorite uh critical
theorists
to see if you can identify the
difference between ct
and ct conspiracy theory and
critical theory that's exciting um i
should add as a caveat
i couldn't do direct citations because
it would give it away
so i sort of dumbed down the
the language of the critical theorists
and sort of elevated
the language of the r r slash conspiracy
subredditors to kind of convolute
like imminent ontologies and stuff like
that it might be a bit of a if i
hear anything about the freemasons or
the knights templar i'm gonna know it's
obviously aristotle's work oh 100 yeah
all right so there's a there's like five
or six of these
number one ct or ct a vaccine id
is similar to when the nazis enforced
identification using the star of david
though not the same intensity the
government will want an id
for all other domains of life perhaps an
id for your religion
or for your political alignment this is
a slippery slope
as is seating any individual liberty to
governments
the mandated curtailment of which must
be resisted at every turn
i'm saying that's either alex yes one by
one
i mean i can't imagine a critical
theorist of any kind of caliber
like voluntarily making a slippery slope
fallacy which they seem to have
based their argument on it so i'm gonna
say it's conspiracy i'm gonna say it's
conspiracy theory too
although it's funny that you say that
eric because literally today when i was
reading over
a little like some stuff in preparation
for this
i was thinking about how sometimes
critical theorists
with their reflect kind of like flowery
language it's
i was actually literally thinking about
how it sometimes seems like they are
making slippery slope fallacies but
without
but not in so many words they kind of
like disguise it at least that was an
accusation i was gonna
bring up at some point that like uh
sometimes there's like an implied
slippery slope argument and
critical theory but it's just harder to
see because of the language that they
use
so is the real conspiracy then that we
need to find the argumentative fallacy
that
i'm gonna proudly use the ad hominem
attack to disprove your argument that is
a well-known
logical maneuver i'm gonna use it now
you're a bad person so
whatever you say is wrong so what's the
truth bills
that when what you're right we had two
two votes
matt abstained but it was conspiracy
oh nice who who said that that was a a
redditer
okay nice they were obviously an english
second language person so i had to uh
dress it up you fixed it i mean you
don't say slippery slope like now
my next argument will be based on the no
true scotsman theory
okay okay buddy okay number two
the purpose that governments pursue
enforced vaccination programs is the
unconditional control
over any movement of citizens completely
analogous to the
internal passport that the soviet regime
had
in order to control the movement from
one city to another
in this case critical theory in this
case however control is even more
absolute
because it concerns any movement of the
citizen who will have to exhibit
vaccinations before every move even to
go to the cinema
attend a concert or sit in a restaurant
oh that's critical theory maybe sounds
critical argument by analogy historical
analogy
that sounds critical to me also like
also kind of like the
the sort of like hyperbolic move to be
like
you know but it's even worse than that
because it's actually like every
qualifying thing
is going to be happening it's like it's
like being like it'll be bad because but
but not only that there's more it's
actually worse than that because it's at
every moment and i feel like that's a
very
critical theory move and then again any
comparison with what is happening in the
west and russia does kind of scream
sort of like not very critical to me it
does it does
it does scream but that's why i think
pills is trying to [ __ ] with us here
he's trying to like so
i would i would say it's uh if i would i
would be
100 confidence critical theory if i were
to investigate that russia reference
yeah yeah yeah it's true the russian
reference does give me some doubt that
maybe it's an
actual conspiracy theory all right we
need votes i'll go with critical
i'm on critical theory yeah uh you know
what i'm gonna mix it up i'm gonna say
conspiracy
it is indeed critical oh wow
hey i thought i [ __ ] up by keeping the
word cinema
in there so that you know oh wow oh yeah
yeah that's a gift
i should have said movie theater that
would have thrown you away
no that's our the talkies that's our boy
agamben
oh wow our favorite wow that's it i also
thought it was just a little too well
written
to be somebody on reddit exactly for
that reason i'm like yeah oh there's
flowery language
reference to like soviets rather than
like the commies or something like that
yeah that's not someone who's making
contractions to fit the 240 characters
that's been thought about
all right number three there is no such
thing as a political science
if there is funding there is politics if
there is politics there is deceit
the science implies that if it comes
from an establishment
and claims to be scientific then
questioning it is blasphemy
unless of course the science in
quotations
comes from an establishment outside the
north atlantic trade organization block
then it's conspiracy theory
oh they're actually using the word in
there i'm gonna say conspiracy theory
just because
the language is all relatively
unspecific and it seems to be fixated on
a specific set of antagonists rather
than structures
so yeah that's what i'm gonna go
honestly that sounds like it could be as
translated from something a french
theorist might have written like
foucault
yeah something like that the the whole
the whole uh anti-scienceness
of the of the kind of pre-90s critical
theory
seemed uh seemed kind of on display
there
i'll i'll go with critical again
i'm gonna go with i'm gonna agree with
matt i'm gonna say conspiracy
the majority is right once more i
thought these might be a little bit
harder but no that is from uh
a reddit post that was tough my initial
implementation was
critical um but matt made a good
argument by the way guys
i got to take a second here because the
cat if you can see him is here and that
means that he
it's time for him to be fed all right
we'll do a quick two more
this one's short our enemy team like
this this is fun
our enemy today is still fascism but
it's the fascism
in our heads and everyday life that
causes us to love power
and hope to be dominated and exploited
oh my god that's
clearly critical theory that sounds
familiar
it's got to be true well that was that
sounds easy yeah it's foucault
from the beginning of uh the intro to
anti-oedipus the preface
that's a classic thing in critical
theory too to talk about the ways in
which
like powers are making us want to be
ruled i thought it might be confusing
because people would call like the cdc a
fascist organization
but i guess they maybe they don't use
those terms it's the fascism in our
heads
it's quite sophisticated also yeah it's
this idea that we're not just dominated
but come to create our own subjection
right right that's what that's a pretty
savvy reddit poster to
start thinking at those multiple levels
i mean like i said before that is like
the central question of anti-oedipus is
how do we come to desire
our own repression all right and here's
the last one
required vaccinations are discrimination
based on personal beliefs and not
scientific certainty
in the scientific field the debate is
still ongoing on the safety and efficacy
of vaccines which according to the
opinion of doctors and scientists
who there is no reason to ignore were
produced quickly and without adequate
testing
i'm gonna go with the conspiracy theory
that sounds familiar too but yeah i'll
go with conspiracy on that one
hey i finally stumped you guys
what guess who that is it's our boy
giorgio gomben
that one that one could have come
straight out of cpac
wow that is actually funny that that's i
mean that shows you what how much he's
gone off the deep end
i guess the verdict is out on that one
whether it's critical or conspiracy
which is sort of the point of the whole
episode
is agon just a leftist conspiracy
theorist
which is why we ended on it so he's uh
he's even left us to gumbin
oh yeah yeah proudly yeah like he's like
marxist tradition yeah so
uh he's calling in to question the
safety
efficacy and this was only last week
by the way so i don't wanna i don't
wanna just dismiss him out of hand
because that's only
one line of course so let's put it into
context
but he's made a few posts lately
this week justifying what he said last
year
and we discussed last year so time's a
flat circle
let's get into it okay so
we're gonna have to get some of the
rhetoric out of this i mean the rhetoric
out of the way
first why don't i just read the most uh
i don't know what to call it i'll just
let you guys react to it this is from
blog post or something it's a gobbins
blog post from
july 16th despite this
those who stick to their free and
well-founded conviction
and refuse to get vaccinated will be
excluded from social life
that the vaccine is thus transformed
into a sort of political
religious symbol aimed at creating
discrimination among citizens
is evident in the irresponsible
declaration of a politician who
referring to those who do not get
vaccinated said without realizing that
he was using fascist jargon
we will purge them with the green pass
the green card constitutes
those who do not have in it bearers of a
virtual
yellow star oh my god
and sorry i stumbled over my words for a
second because uh this was taken from
google translate because i do not read
italian
um the following line after saying the
green card constitutes those who do not
have it
bearers of a virtual yellow star is this
is a fact whose political gravity cannot
be overstated
i mean if somebody really did act like
that was a quote right he said
that they will be purged if they don't
have a green card like if an italian
politician
actually said that then that's i mean to
be fair he's been making exactly these
kinds of claims
since 1997 i think is when homeless
soccer came out
right where he said that the
concentration camp is the new nomos of
the earth
right but the thing is because it's in
an academic text and it's back up with a
lot of references difficult a rant etc
your eyes just kind of glaze over when
you see that you're like oh all right
you know it's a little bit of drama to
end it
but situated in this context it seems a
lot more silly he's doing a
more radical than foucault because
foucault says
all society is a prison and it's based
on the prison he goes a step further and
said
actually all of society is a
concentration camp and
we all live in a concentration camp so i
mean
did some italian politician actually say
that like those who aren't vaccinated
will be purged does he
i'm i'm not sure it is in quotations
but i would assume that he meant we're
gonna purge them from the reopening
process because they won't be allowed to
participate
um apparently in italy you're gonna need
some sort of pass to say that you've
been at least single vaccinated
before you can have dine in eating
go to concerts and go to movie theaters
and things like that so it's not
we're gonna get them all killed it's
exactly the opposite is we're gonna
make them stay at home which a gambin
compares to
a gas chamber staying in your own house
yeah that's
uh well hey first they told the jews to
stay home
slippery slope i'm looking at italian
twitter right now
there is some things about i i put that
line in and so some guy named alberto
buso picked up on it i don't know it
seems like it was an actual
quote maybe that was like floated around
in italian politics or thrown up
on twitter and taken down but it seems
like something
something happened i don't know if it
was this alberto buso guy but it seems
like it is a real quote
someone used the word purge probably in
a hyperbolic manner and then he's just
like picking up on it and like
pergoramo in in italian connell green
pass
the purgaramo is gonna happen to who
gets into a movie theater we're not
we're not gassing people that don't get
the green pass
just to be clear no i imagine what's
gonna happen is now
gembin is going to have to suffer from
italian takeout which
you know if you think about how
seriously italians take their cuisine
and the necessity of like
fresh cuisine at every opportunity is
basically tantamount to death
you know what i mean i also it would be
interesting to know because i don't
actually know what the policy framework
is in italy so it would be interesting
to know whether
um it's whether they're just like making
the green pass and then it's like up to
businesses whether they want to
require them or whether like the
government is mandating that like
you can't go because like i mean i don't
know maybe the effect would be
the same anyway but i guess it just
seems weird like that i mean at least
from the perspective of like having
centralized control that seems pretty
different it's just like having the past
and then it's like
if you're a restaurant you can like
decide to require the pass or not
and like that seems a lot further from
from like control
uh than than like saying that you can't
go to these private businesses without
a pass if that makes sense well let me
read one more
uh quotation this one i think was
deleted since the time that i
it might be up or i might have had
problems with my browser but this is
from july 19th
it's a different post where he justified
the previous post
and he says this in this case control is
even more absolute because it concerns
any movement of the citizen
who will have to exhibit the green pass
for every move even to go to the cinema
attend a concert
or sit in a restaurant the
non-registered citizen will be
paradoxically
freer than the one who is equipped with
it and the mass of registered citizens
should be protesting and rebelling
who from now on will be registered
monitored and controlled to an
unprecedented extent even in regimes
more totalitarian so it's the people
with the past
that he's uh proclaiming concern for
also
because they have to now enter their
name into some sort of uh
database and belong there forever
i also what's remarkable about that is
also how
sharply it deviates from the kind of
position that he took
in state of exception and the earlier
work
without really acknowledging the shift
that's occurring because there the
problem was
the undeterminacy of legal norms that
surrounded
basically undesirables in the community
right and how that allowed you to more
or less do whatever you wanted to them
if you were state actor
now he seems to be shifting to a
different perspective and saying that
people who exist
outside of legal spaces are actually
freer in many senses
than those who are kind of incorporated
into the apparatus he didn't quite
defend but at least eppeld is better
in the earlier books so frankly i just
think he's really
not even being consistent with himself i
was also thinking it would be useful to
also just contrast the position he's
taking now with regard to vaccine
passports
and the the the position he took at the
beginning of the pandemic which was the
subject of
pill pod number three so i don't know
could you refresh the memory of the
listener
oh wasn't that like this was
anti-lockdown when those went just when
the lockdowns were starting yeah when
the last lockdowns were starting and he
was like he talked about how we're being
like reduced to bear life
because we have to stay inside good
yeah good point good point uh first
we were at bear life now we are at
control
society in one year um and this would
probably be a good time to bring up
what terms specifically a gambin is
known for
in ct circles uh he wrote a couple
books at the end of the 90s early 2000s
which seemed to be
really spot on in terms of what happened
after
uh 9 11 namely under the patriot act but
we'll get there
the two terms at least the ones that i
know for
are uh homosacchar which literally
translated means sacred man
but not in the christian sense of the
word
a holy person but sacred as in uh
set apart and set apart here means
you're excluded from
civil society from civil law there's no
punishment for killing you
and the second term which he is known
for is the state of exception
which is what the patriot act
is a is an example of so i think these
are both from the 1988 book which was
called homo soccer and
something else can't remember the
subtitle anyway matt uh
can you give us the deets on
homosacchar first so sure i mean
basically the book actually uh
does have merits i should say uh we can
discuss some people want but
it opens up with this distinction he
makes between uh the greek term
zou right uh which refers to
bear life and bios which is life that
has
a certain kind of meaning or
significance to it
in particular he says that aristotle on
the greeks understood
bios to be life that's meaningful to the
community
and so you're ascribed certain kind of
benefits
including citizenship benefits if you're
considered to belong to the bios
right whereas zou
that's just mere existence and you can
do whatever it is that you want to those
kinds of people right
uh and the argument that he makes is
that
it's kind of vague quite frankly at some
point in modernity uh with the emergence
of the nation state
uh more and more people were kind of
pushed out of the category of belonging
to the bios
or that kind of life which has
significance for the political community
and were shouted in to the category of
zou which is better life that you can
treat however it is that you want
and the image that he brings and there's
a few of them is this homosacker or the
individual who sacrificed for the sake
of the community he also brings up
uh the notion of the muslim man so the
muslim man was basically
an individual in a concentration camp a
nazi concentration camp right
uh who was so stripped of their
personality that all that was left was
their kind of biological functioning
right
uh they had no will they had no interest
and the state could do whatever it is
that they wanted to them
because they had no capacity to even
object to that any longer right
and the argument he makes is that in
their contemporary biopolitical era
more and more people are getting shunted
into these kinds of categories
uh where the law doesn't choose to
recognize them grant them any kind of
rights or any kind of
capacity to be citizens but it doesn't
disregard
them because it also sees them as a
threat and to a certain extent
and so it tries to manage them through
the application of
basically violent forms of power right
which is why he says that
the concentration camp has now become
the no most of the earth right
uh with refugees for example being
shunted into you know these giant gated
communities where the state will do
whatever they want
it wants to them uh without any kind of
legal oversight
or gitmo is the example that he uses
quite prominently
in the state of exception book right the
americans will bring prisoners from
their various wars on terror there where
so they can do whatever it is they want
to them
none of this by the way i think accords
very much with what's happening in
reality
and we can talk about that i actually
think that the liz piece
uh is a lot more sophisticated when it
talks about actually how it is that if
anything
uh we're now more regulated by different
kinds of legalities
than ever before um but you know more
one more interesting point is that homo
saccharo is actually
a uh something from pre-christian roman
law
a person i guess person declared homo
soccer
is allowed to be killed by anybody but
you're not allowed to uh
sacrifice them in a uh a religious
ritual or some some
something like that so i guess we we end
up getting our word sacred
sacred from sacker but i guess in this
context it means they're kind of
desacralized you know they're up there
they are uh
legitimate purge victims yeah yeah so
it's a legal
it's a legal term that denotes absolute
stripping of all life including the
ability to live
like you you wait you won't be punished
for killing them so i assume your own
slaves
like you could you could kill them
without with impunity
well actually it's really enough that's
one of the points that he makes which is
that in roman society
some slaves did have rights to be
protected from their masters
right uh so the hammer soccer was in
some sense as a person who was
subordinated even to the slave
uh because i couldn't just go over to
your house if i was a patrician
and kill your slaves for example because
you're the owner they're their owner
right and they have certain rights if
you want through you right
uh homo soccer has no rights because no
one even wants to bother
oppressing them per se um they're just a
threat to the community
existing outside of it or sometimes as a
part of it but not welcome there
so in this context the implication of
what he's saying
now is something like if you're not
immunized you become
homo soccer because uh you have to stay
home which is
overstating the point i i know let's try
to take it a little bit seriously if we
can
but i did want to just quickly bring up
the second term that is associated with
the gambin which is a state of exception
which means that in any exceptional
circumstance
ie a covid lockdown you can trust that
the government
is going to take full advantage and use
every opportunity
to impinge on your individual liberties
using that state of exception
as an excuse so the idea is that
something that is a state of exception
we could think of uh 9 11 and the
patriot act
right they say well we're doing this for
your own protection
but they use it to snap up any types of
surveillance
control management over your life that
they can
whenever such a state arises and this
was his argument
one year ago also yeah and i just want
to add
he did not come up with this himself uh
a far more smart and interesting guy
called carl schmidt came up with it
uh by the way schmidt was an evil man
right nazi anti-semite all that kind of
stuff but his books are nonetheless
fascinating right
but what he kind of talks about is how
there's a routine juridical order that
exists
that kind of allocates rights and
privileges to citizens
um but the person who's really the boss
the sovereign if you want
is the one who gets to decide when that
legal order becomes suspended
uh and it's quite an interesting claim
right because you're essentially the one
who's allowed almost this god-like power
to say the normal rules don't apply
i'm going to replace them with a
different set of rules uh that according
to my will
and my existential inception of what
should be right and a gambin's
argument innovating on this a little bit
is to say that the fundamental power
of the sovereign and the sovereign state
uh isn't necessarily decide whether to
suspend the juridical order or not
is to get to decide who is included in
the body politic and who is not
who gets to be bios and who gets to be
zoe right
uh and his argument is that increasingly
states are deciding that
most people even those who would have
traditionally thought get to be included
in the community don't get to be
bios they are zoe right uh they have no
legal status whatsoever
we can do whatever it is that we wish to
them and i'm way outside of my area of
expertise here but
can you uh confirm or deny matt but i
think uh
hitler went to schmidt to
make it so that he could justify legally
the fuhrer laws
so that nothing the fiera could do could
be illegal
because he embodies the will of the
people is that right
yeah it's very interesting right so
schmidt has
a lot of complicated thoughts on this
i'll just summarize them really quickly
right um
originally schmidt was actually kind of
a conservative nationalist with a few
christian inclinations
and he supported the nationalist uh
german party but one of the things that
he argued
was look like the nazis are gaining
power the only way you're going to be
able to prevent them from seizing power
or the bolsheviks seizing power which is
going to be even worse
is by establishing a conservative
dictatorship and which makes schmidt
interesting as he kind of has this
nietzschean idea which is that
the problem with the ruling class in
germany at the time is that
it's too weak to defend itself uh it
doesn't have the balls to just go out
there suspend the juridical order
and crush and liquidate the soviets and
for that matter also the social
democrats
so later on when it becomes clear that
hitler is willing to do that and then so
and more so um he kind of tacks on to
hitler and says well hitler is this
person
who kind of embodies the logic of what
i'm talking about
because he's willing to form a ruling
test that will
speak for the people by determining
what their identity is going to be
and if he's able to create such a strong
affinity between
his will and the will of the people in
some senses schmitz would say this would
be more democratic than what you find in
a representative system
uh it would be a total system right
where the fury wills
one thing and the people's will lines
with him
absolutely and it's directed in this way
and he said this would be
very much what so even wanted with this
idea of a general will because there's
an affinity between what the fuhrer
wants and what the people want whereas
representative to democracy with its
party system
uh there's nothing like this right you
know you have your party in power
sometimes they get to implement one
policy or another then another party
comes to power they get to implement
their policy or another
uh but there's no kind of total
organization of the people directed in
one
way so if i'm not mistaken um
agaben also formulated it in terms of
something called a permanent state of
exception
where you have the the idea of these um
you know super supranational
organizations that
can you know declare health emergencies
or other sorts of things like that like
the w.h.o
and there's a lot of talk of this
actually during the swine flu if anyone
remembers that uh in the canadian press
it was written there
and this was written in the in in the
canadian press
back then it said there have been
allegations that who was in leak with
the pharmaceutical industry declaring
h1n1
pandemic to generate windfall products
for companies making vaccine and
antiviral drugs
so a lot this talk is not new
this sort of thing he's running through
with this
current pandemic has been rehearsed
before
both in his theory and you know this has
been thought about both by people and
by everyone involved who governments
you know whatever the the national
disease
organizations in various countries and
stuff this is all
you know this is all old hat kind of
pandemic stuff
it's not brand new to kovit kova is just
the most exceptional exception of all of
them
i just want to shift to the latter half
of the discussion
which is pretty much just even rhetoric
aside
we don't want to be making holocaust
comparisons to justify our theoretical
positions and everything but
the last question that will occupy the
rest of the episode is just
is a gambin right is there something to
be concerned about here
um and we can bring up the de la's text
that we read if uh that's of interest
as well anyway victor sorry i mean like
if you look back
at history of pandemics there's actually
someone in my department at the
university of toronto who's a theorist
and wrote about like before covet
happened she was writing about um
pandemics
like historical examples of pandemics
like like the plague right plague
politics
so she just i remember her talking about
how like you know there was
actually in some ways like much stronger
uh like a self-isolation and like
it would be more at the town level but
like i mean i guess the point is like
this isn't like new right like trying to
sort the people who are like a threat to
the community and who aren't
like that's you know it's just i guess
the way that it's being mechanized and
standardized i suppose is the thing that
agon finds disturbing
yeah i should also say it's worth noting
who he's trying to respond to with his
work
uh the primary public political foil is
foucault right
famously in the first volume of history
of sexuality said we need to stop
talking about state sovereignty
really we shouldn't even be interested
in the state at all uh it's time to cut
off the head of the king and talk about
discourse of power uh biopower all that
kind of stuff right
and i think a genmen did a good thing in
the 1990s and through
2000s of emphasizing that no the state
is not going away
it still plays a major role uh in
creating systems of power and domination
uh and it also gets decide
in no small part who gets to be included
uh in certain structures of power as a
citizen and who does not
right uh i think he just goes way too
far and trying to theorizing this
i should say miss theorizing this by
appealing to schmidt
right because his kind of argument is
that
what schmidt offers him is an account of
how it is that
there's all these people who aren't
governed by the law have no rights have
no kinds
of legal apparatuses surrounding them at
all uh which is precisely why the state
can do whatever it wants to them
right it's an idea picks up on hannah
and rent i think that what i like the
delivers piece for
uh is delis points out that actually if
anything
uh the state is more militant than ever
in creating new kinds of legal and
regulatory categories
to control people uh and that has been
complemented by international
institutions that are backed up by state
power
non-um legal institutions like large
corporations
who interact in many cases with states
right
so i think this idea that there are such
things as legal black holes as he
sometimes calls it
where bail life exists and where the
state enacts its violence
is just really a fantasy that only
exists in his mind and it's also not
what schmidt was getting at either
when he was talking about this idea of a
state of exception right so
a gambin does some good things and i
want to give him credit for that because
i think foucault kind of overstated his
thesis with that
but a lot of the stuff is just kind of
bunk to my mind
yeah yeah for sure you know i think um
i mean on the question of whether he's
right or wrong i think that
i i do think that he's he's wrong and i
think
you know thinking back to our earlier
episode where we talked about a gun but
i think one of the comments i made
sort of as as a i thought i thought a
garmin was a good example of somebody
who has like a theoretical framework
and they just like push it on to the
reality that they find themselves in
yeah
like justified their framework and i
feel like that
the problem with that is that it ends up
like preventing you from analyzing like
the nuance of the situation and like the
specificity and particularity of like
what's actually happening
and instead he's like oh i was right
about my state of exception and like
homosexual and it's like look at how it
all fits into my framework and it's just
like
that's when i think like critical theory
like gets a little out of control and in
the weeds when it's just like it's
prioritizing
like the the cogency and applicability
of the theory
over just like being like well what what
are the reasons for
um thinking through the specificity of
the reality
uh and the context in a way that you
know has its own
specific considerations that maybe don't
fit into like his kind of like nefarious
narrative of control and and domination
by by state actors that he wants to tell
yeah i think that's 100 true
i mean like i met a lawyer who actually
worked on behalf of gitmo prisoners and
one of the things that he told me was
this account of gitmoa is a state of
exception or a space of exception
uh where there's kind of really no laws
surrounding what you can do to these
people which is why they want to put
them there
is just wrong right if anything he
points out there's
unbelievable amounts of regulation and
laws and quasi-legal entities that
govern what you can do to these people
u.s law cuban law international law
various kinds of international law right
and if anything
these overlapping systems of control
whether legal or otherwise
are what's part of the problem in trying
to obtain justice for these kinds of
individuals
right because you have to go through so
many loopholes in order to even
try to advocate on their behalf and i
think that's exactly the same thing that
you're seeing
here right which is that if anything
what he seems to be complaining about is
the state is now creating more
categories through which it's going to
rank
organize and control people uh this
overlaps with
many non-state forms of organization
that are associated with coveting
vaccines
right uh so it's not this exceptional
space right it's much more in line with
what
liz is talking about right can we can we
like we gotta pull back for a second
look
at the sort of general theory of
gammon's coming in with and
maybe compare it with also deliza's
postscript on societies of control right
that
where the the locus the locus of power
is becoming the corporation rather than
the state
and even in this case we can say that
these green passes are not
the state right they are multiple states
coordinating through the efforts of
super state organizations
right so there's no the state here
imposing this there's a collection of
different actors that are trying to have
this
put into place because it's going to
facilitate what business and travel
and and all sorts of things but the idea
is that
you know i guess from the societies of
control perspective the idea is that our
classical institutions
which we considered interiors like the
prison right is an
interior but in the societies of control
those
interiors spill out into the general you
know there's no more distinction they
spill out
across the world and these control
mechanisms that were
you know in control understood very
broadly but these control mechanisms
that used to be confined to the school
the factory the prison and all of these
other sorts of what we used to think of
as state apparatuses
are becoming decentralized and detached
from
national organizations they're not
they're becoming denationalized in a way
and becoming global you know and so
the idea that the state is doing this
is is not correct it is the idea that
it's a kind of
a kind of cooperative thing happening
right so you have to kind of approach it
from that it's important to say
it's not just the state that's doing
that because i think a gentleman would
push back rightly and say or perhaps
even primarily the state right who do
you think is pushing these things the
people who have the
financial and economic interests which
are partly the state
but they're partly other actors too
other big powerful actors that have
an interest in you know resuming air
travel
resuming tourism resuming all of those
sorts of things
that we've had to either put massive
restrictions on or stopped entirely
i think that's exactly right and that
he's he seems almost passe
in saying that this is an act of the
state when everything that he's saying
would apply far more to regular
passports
than to covet passports so in that sense
like this is not
this is not new stuff it's just like
something new for him to complain about
but if you think about what politicians
actually want do you think they want
control
or do they just want re-election what's
their re-election going to be based on
it's going to be on
managing the death rate to say yeah
keeping the numbers down in the micro
political sense like they're trying to
have as many people die
as possible and then to be as open for
business
as soon as possible we want to say our
country's over
open for business we stopped covet so
in that like if that's their motivation
which is not that conspiratorial to
suggest at all
then they want their country open so
having a
having a passport for vaccines services
that end by saying we're gonna
if you don't want to get the vaccine
fine but then you're not going to be
able to
go spend your money but then everybody
else can spend their money
and then like i think what delis gets so
much better than a gobbin
is like eric said this is going to be
privatized like i'd be surprised in
10 15 years if we can even buy our own
cars
it's just gonna be you rent the car from
the company
and you can't even own anything anymore
like it already
and it drives itself hey janet tries to
sell and it's got a limit of how much
co2 you're allowed to emit during your
time uh
using it and maybe you'll have to buy
extra co2 chips
but in terms of what you can use what
you rent from companies
i mean we've already seen it in terms of
software like you have to
you have to purchase software licenses
you can't actually
own things i think the direction that we
see a society of control going
is not in terms of legal
systems it's far more in terms of here's
your
here's your consumer date centric here's
your consumer options and this is not a
singular
state like you said this is multiple
overlapping states that control your
access to this control your access to
that
and that seems to me to be a much more
realistic vision
of this dystopian future not that the
state is going to suddenly turn into
something that it
hasn't looked like for a long time
frankly what kind of thing can i just
quickly
say that that that although it's worth
pointing out that like the
it's interesting how there's like a
conservative overlap though that like
so you know we talk about how this is
all in the interest of making sure that
we can all go back to business as usual
so that businesses can flourish
and stuff but it's actually precisely a
lot of like the right wing
pro business who want things to be open
and don't want the passport because the
passport means
that like you have to have that people
have to get vaccinated and especially in
a place like the us that only has like
55
vaccination um that means that a lot of
those people aren't going to be able to
go back to business so there's actually
like a tremendous amount of business
interests that are against
also the vaccine passport which is just
kind of interesting how there might be
like an overlap between like
a right-wing and left-wing critique of
like of of the of the covent management
stuff
i think you're exactly right that what
he does is it kind of sees these things
everywhere
and regardless of the actual material
social or cultural
context or the transitions that have
occurred he still just tends to read
them in there
right i do think that like you could
make a strong case that
this argument about a state of exception
that creates a homeless soccer
does apply in what's really his best
case study which is nazi germany
right because that's exactly what they
did uh to the jews and other
undesirables in the nazi state right i
think it's also
the case that in that kind of context an
analysis of state power and totalitarian
state power
was the primary task that critical
theory should set for itself
right but for all the reasons that eric
mentioned that pills mentioned
i just think it's extremely outdated now
to assume that we need to put this kind
of weight on the state
uh and the legal system uh to try to
account for
why it is that all these unusual things
are happening
i think that the one thing that he gets
right is that we can't just decide to
ignore the state which is what some
people
i mean i'd go so far as to say that the
state doesn't even want to control
because it's too much work
they're more than happy to and they're
all that's true they're all too busy
appealing to their base
right like the the the only reason that
for like a gambin is anti-vaccine pass
and our conservative government
doug ford has also said he's
anti-vaccine pass is because
ford is trying to appeal to the big the
tin hat
constituency who doesn't want to get
covid and they're all libertarians and
ridiculous people
and agaben is doing it for a very
different reason he's also concerned
with avoiding having a split society
but for all the sorts of theoretical
reasons we mentioned earlier about
states of exceptions and homosackers and
things like that
i i think what a gomban sees is again a
progress towards a more totalitarian
society of control
rather than you know maybe like a
delusion decentralized
society of control where control is
actually administered by the person
to themselves right we control ourselves
in a sense right we impose certain
restrictions on ourselves in the same
sort of sense that
you know pyeongchang's burnout society
is also a kind of internal policing
right that's that's what delusion is
going for and i don't know i'm not
saying yeah
gobbins on that train but he i think
he's going in
that direction so the very fact of you
know if you're going to split it into a
binary are you for
or against vaccine passes well yeah of
course all the liberals are
for a vaccine pass but he's saying you
know if you're a little too
you know maybe if you're a little too
enthusiastic about these vaccine passes
and saying [ __ ] the people who don't get
them and [ __ ] all these people
isn't that a little purgey you know
isn't that just a little bit of a purge
mentality
someone who has someone maybe not who
does want uh
who does think that there's a lot of
good arguments for the vaccine pass
i think that you should have you know to
use the word exception a lot of
exceptions like if you have certain like
health risks obviously
like if there's like a good
justification for why you're not getting
the vaccine then i think that that
should be permissible and you should be
given the past that you can still
participate in society
but otherwise like you just aren't
comfortable with it like i don't know
[ __ ] you well like i say you want to go
to like i'm pro-science
but i am anti-big pharma you know i'm
coming off of this hangover of bernie
sanders
campaigning for the last many years on
we need to
take power away from pharmaceutical
companies they have too
much power and then boom that whole line
of discourse on the left seems to have
just been completely and magically
suspended
and now we're all for big farms
isn't there a slippage sometimes though
i find that sometimes when we like the
left or critical theorists we start
analyzing these kinds of social and
political phenomena we
we talk about like we look at who's
benefiting and i think that that's like
important it's good to be like who's
benefiting right pharmaceutical
companies are benefiting private
and private interest is benefiting and
like all that's true but i i sometimes
feel like
well that's true it's also important to
be like we also all of us benefit from
like ending this this this pandemic like
like so
like it's just the problem is like when
the interests of business and and and
pharma
overlap with just like our normal
interest in like having a society where
we're not to be scared right like
ultimately
if we weren't taking any measures and
everyone was just allowed to do whatever
they wanted and go wherever they want
like yeah it's true we'd have no like
overarching
businesses or like private capital
interests dominating us and influencing
us
we would all have this fear about like
who is who
like like they did in the black plague
it's like you don't know who's infected
and you're just like scared all the time
you interact with people and the whole
point of these like measures is try to
like end that state where we're all
scared
and i guess like i think that there can
be a problem when you over when we
overemphasize
the sort of uh well look at all these
like big powerful interests that are
benefiting and it's like when that's the
emphasis i feel like we
we can risk losing sight of just like
but also like this just sucks for
everybody like we just need to
we just need to get rid of this and and
i'll just like briefly end by
asking kind of a question that i noticed
in the in the liz article
and it's come up in other places the
word domination comes up and i guess
you know i mean we may not have time to
get into this but i i like wonder
sometimes when we're talking about like
forms of domination self-imposed
domination like
what would it be to be not dominated
like like what would exactly a society
look like where there's no forms of
domination i mean maybe no one would
claim that that's possible but i guess
i'm just
i kept wondering that i just want to
build off a point with a tasteful uh
dragon ball z reference by saying
uh gammon sorry about power level dragon
ball z
dragon ball z excuse me yeah it's just
let's be proper he reached his peak
power level in the early 2000s mid-2000s
i think justifiably precisely because
during the war on terror it did really
seem like a lot of these anxieties about
the state
warranted a comeback right a lot of
people were deeply concerned about
american empire
the patriot act more people going to
jail and ashley speaks to a bit of what
victor was talking about earlier on as
well
that a gunman describes very effectively
right which is this atmosphere of fear
that leads you to turn to power in order
to
create systems of domination that keep
us safe right
and i imagine if you were to talk to him
he'd say that something very similar is
going on right now which is essentially
that we're willing to
surrender our freedoms if not to the
state but to various forms of power
in order to get that kind of nice warm
fuzzy safe feeling
that you're talking about right my
argument would be that i think that is
definitely a worry
and i think that you can see instances
of that for instance in hungary
uh where viktor orban and vidaz
basically created an authoritarian
government exactly on the back of covid
right but i also do think that there are
more benign kinds
of institution-making
and regulatory schemes that are
necessary
in order for us not necessarily to give
power to certain people
but for all of us to get back to our
lives as normal right
and i don't think gambit can sometimes
see the distinction between the two
and sometimes it's blurry uh but
sometimes i just don't think it's really
all that blurry at all well i mean
he must have got because he wrote the
book in 98. he must have totally got
high on his own supply
after 9 11. because then we have like
two
no there is like this isn't even my
final form yet there going to be five
more
homo soccer he's got like two nonsense
wars
plus the patriot act plus the
revelations about the patriot act so
certainly probably got
uh high on his own supply yeah and i
mean it's absolutely true that people
in conditions of high anxiety will turn
to
forces that are willing to dominate them
in order to get a sense of security
i don't think anybody would deny that
and that's been a theme in political
theory and for that matter
literary tragedy going back to the
ancient greeks right uh we just need to
be careful to demarcate
when that's what's going on and when
people are taking relatively benign
regulatory measures as a community
to protect the most vulnerable members
amongst also it's also interesting
because earlier i was saying like
we're also trying to protect so it's
true that the government or like other
powerful interests will
use fear to like pursue their own
interests
but also like the flip side of that is
like in a pandemic like we're also
trying to
take measures so that we don't have to
live in fear right because if
literally nobody did anything and just
said
everything's fine people would just
start dying and then we would all be
like scared because we wouldn't know why
and we would all be like scared to go
out like if no one investigated it or
did anything so it's like
i have to make a claim i hope that
nobody clips this and no one
ever takes this out of context but in
this context
this is gonna be great it will be i am
very thankful for the conspiratorial
right wing
because i know that if the libs were in
charge they would have [ __ ] chipped
us all already
but because those evangelical psychos
are scared of the mark of the beast
we're never getting chipped because
there's just way too many of them and
they're way too crazy
they're not gonna get any tattoo they're
gonna get no barcode they're gonna get
no chips
and they're they're protecting us from
that because we're uh too much
too too big of [ __ ] to stand up for
when the line's been growing chips would
be much easier to trace people back to
the already existing database of many
people's information
which is undoubtedly the green pass is
just
the front of a database that everyone's
going to be on
right but the fact that the the green
pass is something
that is aimed up to open the economy
right get
business back open is already like a
baseline we've all kind of accepted that
that needs to happen
okay well maybe we should stand back and
ask like does that really need to happen
though
because the only people getting
wealthier and wealthier during this
pandemic are people
not [ __ ] me definitely jeff bezos
all those [ __ ] in space right now
whatever they're doing up there
and other people look at me i i agree
with pharmaceutical companies right so
what's the necessity
for the most of us to open the economy
back up it's there is no necessity for
the average person that's not all
most people actually have jobs like in
the service industry they're getting
[ __ ] by not being able to go to work
and like
do i like the fact that actually like
like all these private interests like
that are powerful are getting stuff like
no i don't but like there's actually
like
a huge number of like regular low-income
people who are like going to be [ __ ]
and it's not sustainable like a lot of
people who work in restaurants and all
kinds of service industries we can we
have those going again without the green
pass we don't need the green pass the
green pass is meant to facilitate
travel because different countries have
different protocols if you're fully
vaccinated partially vaccinated or
non-vaccinated
they have different protocols and that's
what it's for it's not for getting
people back to work
i agree that that's true but it's also
true
that the green pass would also protect
people who work in the service industry
have to face
like if we're going to reopen global
travel with people like if i work in a
restaurant and i'm like some low income
person
it's like i would rather know that the
people who are coming into the
restaurant had the green pass so that
way i would know that they were
vaccinated and that wouldn't put me
and my family in a safer position again
that just seems to say that
the corporations that are employing
these people
actually have a care about them which i
think they've demonstrated
to the nth degree that they do not give
a [ __ ] about frontline workers
whatsoever look at our
big magnanimous company lobbyists
refused sick pay they don't give a [ __ ]
about
that's a motive you're placing behind
the green pass that isn't there
it's there is no motivation behind
introduction it doesn't matter the most
you originally started this conversation
by talking about like who's benefiting
and what would be the harm of not
doing it and i was saying well there are
actually people who benefit who are due
from doing it
whether or not there's the intention to
protect those people like i agree
probably like that's not their primary
concern but like it's still it's still
worth like thinking about how it does
i don't think it should be decided by a
cost-benefit analysis
and in any case i think it's a lesser of
two eagle arguments that
no individual has the computational
power to
decide so in a sense we do have to lean
back on our principles and our morals
a little bit on questions like this and
you know
bombastic rhetoric aside and all
holocaust comparisons
aside i think gobbin does have a very
good point
about the motivations behind this sort
of thing
and the idea that you know okay let's
not call it a purge
but everyone who doesn't have a green
pass is in a sense
excluded from rejoining society
and like you can't say okay but the
people who don't have a green pass don't
just don't want it to get vaccinated
because they're right wing
and they are tin hat wearing paranoiacs
but that
that shouldn't be beside they are still
human beings unfortunately
so we have to think about their needs
and in that sense like we shouldn't
have this sort of purge mentality behind
the green pass
but unfortunately on social media the
sort of excited vigor that a lot of the
leftists and liberals are getting behind
this green past
again i say it's a little bit pergy in
the way that they disregard human life
just because they disagree with the
person's fundamental view on things
right i don't know one of the good
things to come out of this pandemic and
very little good came out of it right
um was that i did actually see people
become more mobilized around
provincial and federal politics than
they have in a long time
on behalf of their federal citizens like
their fellow citizens right so i don't
think it's all bad
and i think it's a good example of what
victor was talking about so the forward
government
really dragged its heels on implementing
something like paid sick days
for people in low-income service
industries tile jobs
right probably in part because it was
going to be prohibitively expensive
either for the province
uh or for the companies if they had to
internalize those costs
and people became outraged enough about
this when numbers went high enough
that they demanded that he take action
on it and then the federal government
put pressure on him
and eventually he caved right so i see
this is a good example of how it is that
you can encourage people to
start rethinking fundamental issues of
political economy
which will be my marxist point to end on
i guess right which is that
uh it's not all bad if we can encourage
people to take this as a moment
to ask themselves if they want that kind
of solitaristic society
where we use various forms of state
power or other power
in order to make these companies work
for us rather than us work for them
right i mean i think we could i feel
like we actually
had more to talk about so maybe we
should do uh like a part two
because i i feel like there's there's
unresolved uh
questions here it's just eric and you
know it's like the alex jones things you
get his
soul gets near that evil and he just
goes like oh no
no i can't do it not the pharmaceutical
companies no way no world order
we started this episode totally
accidentally
talking about uh being charged for dlc
and i think that's what it is right
downloadable content that's right okay
i thought i might have got the word
wrong but uh i think that's
the most uh crucial difference to
recognize here is that agambin's
conspiracy theory i mean in a in a
proper sense
seems a little bit passe in terms of
him thinking that like the government
is in control and i think we're seeing
more and more evidence that
that control is waning and that control
is becoming
decentralized and we'll invade our life
at a more
microscopic level every day but it's not
going to be the government doing that
yeah yeah that's a really good point and
i also think that that
you know reading the delivers piece too
made me think that
we should just talk more about that
concept of control and i mentioned
earlier domination
and i think that that would make for a
very good future episode because i think
that there's some interesting
vagueness to what exactly control and
domination mean in the critical theory
context i think there's
potentially a lot of concept creep about
there but we don't have time for that
now control i need to shout out to
myself and my new video control is a
cybernetic term
that is meant to be contrasted to the
new video contrast with domination
because
domination implies that you
dominate yourself and your own behavior
in public
visibly whereas control becomes more
invisible
more uh subconscious even control
kibernetti's the uh the steersman of the
ship and the root word for the word
government i wanted to say something in
line with like that what sheldon mullen
said and i guess i'll end with that
right which is that
i actually think the kind of anti-status
rhetoric that pills
rightly invoked right actually can
sometimes be problematic when it comes
to trying to push for progressive
politics
precisely because what you see the
political right doing right now a great
deal
is suggesting that precisely because
there's so many other forces of control
out there that the state
cannot and should not regulate we
shouldn't even bother trying to do that
right which can lead people to
conclusion that their own
democracy will not work for them because
there's too much external to it
that's kind of hedging it in a certain
way which isn't to try to defend the
state or say that we should necessarily
fetishize the state but i do think you
know what we've seen with povid
and it's the best moments as people
organizing solitairistically to demand
that the state
put pressure on these systems of control
for working people
right and i'd hope that we'd see more of
that in the future you think you can
just sneak that in
as your last point first of all i did
not invoke anti-state
rhetoric at least not the way a gombin
does i said
on record that the government
bureaucracy is a bunch of lazy bastards
who are fully
willing to give any amount of their
duties over to the private sector
like hey peter thiel uh can you please
go find us the terrorists on the
internet
hey whoever else can you build us a
robotic prison to lock all these
terrorists up the peter patio found
we'll give you a 10 billion dollar
dod contract and then you want to say oh
no we should be rebuilding
faith in those institutions a lot of
[ __ ] gold to mine there
no thanks obama we did the hopi changey
[ __ ] so [ __ ] that
we're not ending on a lib note eric gets
the last word yeah i mean
i would i would love the state to have
more control but then that would mean
that they would have to expand
their concerns from their extremely
narrow band of concerns
to like job numbers like we were just
saying and
you know the appealing to their base and
those sorts of very
sorts of pragmatic near future politic
kind of real politic concerns we need a
state
that gives a [ __ ] about other things
than what gets them
the heart the people who work for it
re-elected which
yeah sure i think that's a that's a
maybe is still lip but [ __ ] it
well i just want to reiterate uh thank
you to the right-wing conspiracy
theorists
clip that who are certainly not
listening to this but thank you for
protecting us against the chip
alright guys it's been fun let's uh
pick it up again at some point in the
future we'll do part three
again quarantine again part three
you